all right y'all
we are back live once again
and wait we turn this up once again and
let's get it in
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
with me
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to ripping
with Griffin
show today huge show today the Celtics
epic collapse the succession finale
Elon wants to put chips in our head
so much more news and notes 100 it's
always just me being me and I appreciate
you being here as always
[Music]
chat interact have fun cause you know
isn't real feelings
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to riffing
with Griffin uh here we are once again
riffing it with Griffin it
um you know how we do let me see let me
get uh let me get all this
nonsense going over here you know uh as
I always say all right let me move this
this is on my mouse as I always say make
sure you subscribe I appreciate a good
subscribe uh you know hit the
notifications so you know when I'm going
live or you know when I'm posting videos
I'm on Twitch daily you know what I mean
Eric Griffin gaming come check me out
you can also be a supporter there you
could sub there you could be a YouTube
member which is great too um
to support me on the Tron you know the
patron and uh I love all that so I
appreciate all the love and support
anything you guys can do I appreciate
that and that's always like I say
what I'm about to say appreciate it
so I I thanks you like I say thanks for
being here guys
um I'm going to be in
um where am I going to be Nashville
um yeah I'm gonna be in Nashville
on June 21st at Zanies for one night and
then for the rest of the weekend I'm
gonna be in Huntsville so if you are in
that area come check me out
um
you know and then I'm gonna be in
Chicago in July so all that stuff is on
my crazy website ericgriffin.com which
oh I also have to like change that
because when you look at it on the phone
I didn't fix the yeah I don't know I did
one day I'm gonna get a new site you
know what I mean I'm just gonna like
break down I get so many problems I get
so many emails from people who were like
let me help you let me help you let me
help you and I just like I don't know
who to pick you know it's
it's a lot y'all you know what I mean it
it really it really is a lot so
um anyways
let's see uh what's going on this week
um anything happen this week I don't
know nothing really nothing really
dramatic happened this we finally got a
bed
so our bed is on the way you know we
actually end up getting a Tempur-Pedic
um as you guys know about that crazy
hostage hostings whatever 70 000
mattress story what was crazy about that
though is I will say the one good thing
is the the presentation that the guy
gave it's stuck in my mind it really did
it stuck in my mind and so
um the things he was saying about how
you should feel and the one that got me
was this and I'll tell you then I'll
move on to comments what got me was this
was that he said you should be able to
lay in one position on the proper bed
for hours
so like you should be able to lay on
your back on your bed and you should be
able to lay like that for hours if you
can't if at a certain point you start
feeling discomfort it's because you have
the wrong mattress and I was like and
that stuck with me
every mattress store we went to after
that but we ended up getting a
Tempur-Pedic which it ain't cheap let me
tell you it ain't cheap but you know
Daddy's doing okay you know what I mean
so
we got that all right
um let's get into some comments because
uh you know like I say I always
appreciate when people comment on stuff
you know
uh some Mark 7303 just 12 minutes ago
said can't believe I just [__] found
this God damn it Eric I love you can't
spell my name right though but thank you
Mark
uh
so then uh that we got
Immaculate records 305
um this guy said when you people when
you people going to learn feeling in
Boston we're never real contenders
I don't agree with that but you know
it's always like Monday morning
quarterbacking and we will be talking
all about the Celtics collapse
uh some uh what's this one Austin
something entertainment Idol was rigged
because we we
what he said a we and should have won oh
yeah she was good but I I disagree with
you
um
I didn't mention her name because I
wasn't a fan but she's great
but she was too dramatic I thought I
thought she was too it was it didn't
feel genuine you know like it was very
like presentational like you know
I'm an idol you know what I mean like
every time she sung she was like I'm
singing
oh you know and then she had that weird
voice but she's great and she's gonna be
a star so if you're a fan of hers I'm
sorry that I didn't mention her I wasn't
a super fan but I'm acknowledging right
now she was fantastic
um
let's see uh what else we got here
um let's see somebody said Mr j15 I hope
you're a wrong champ Well turns out I
was wrong but I didn't really predict
the Celtics win I just said this was the
formula where someone could win you know
let's see what else we got here
uh
I don't know I don't know I don't know
uh let's see where we at here
okay um monster zero zero three three
I was watching a news story on TV and
this top business guy who was working
with AI and it being introduced into the
business World claims once AI is
established into the workplace 40 of
American jobs will be replaced by them
by 2030. a quarter of American workers
are expected to lose their jobs as a
result of AI and replace 800 million
human jobs also 100 000 robots are ready
to replace human workers at Amazon's
warehouses
can't I'm gonna thanks for bringing this
up gonna talk about this
um you know it's it's just we just need
to get our [__] together and start
changing our learning but we'll get into
all that right
um
somebody said this deserves way more
than 26 000 views I totally agree with
you I
uh
all right anyways a lot of good comments
thanks for thanks for being here and
also thanks for the shout outs on the uh
Apple podcast uh appreciate those
comments too
um you know and even sometimes even
sometimes I'll get like let me go to
this real quick even sometimes I'll get
some like you know sorted uh negative
back and forth but sometimes people
sometimes people come back man and
they're like
you know they come back after having say
a bad interaction and then they they
think about it so this guy right here
Devin hogston he sent me a message said
hey man I just wanted to apologize for a
back and forth we had on YouTube a few
weeks ago involving Trump Fox and Tucker
Carlson I was just thinking about it
watching your episodes of Harlan Harlan
Highway and I was just on a Harlan
Williams podcast that guy's hilarious I
feel bad because I did not in any way
mean to upset you or make you feel a
certain way I just wanted to have a
conversation you know and then of course
he goes on to like more of our
interaction but anyways sometimes that
happens and that's what it's all about
it's just like you know even if you get
heated you come back you're like you
know what I thought about it and I'm all
about that so shout out to that guy
thanks for uh you know thanks for just
interacting and just remember you don't
it doesn't always have to be such a like
a negative thing you know what I mean it
doesn't you know sometimes it could just
be uh you know you just have a strong
opinion and that's okay okay you know
what I mean like it's okay to have a
strong opinion about stuff man
um
what else like I say if you comment on
all the other the audio platforms thanks
for that I guess I got to start pulling
those up and reading those but the only
thing with those is like those that area
actually can be very toxic but I do see
a lot of positive comments there so I
appreciate that you know
it's funny it's like I guess you only
want positive comments uh you know
as opposed to like I think you want
positive comments and constructive
criticism
but if people hate you like I always
feel like why are you wasting energy
commenting on why you don't like it not
even being constructive just like being
like I'm giving you a one and I'm never
watching this again Bubba you're wasting
all your energy on that so it's just
like there are a lot there are comments
like that which like you know I don't
know it's kind of funny you know it
really is kind of funny so but anyways
once again thanks for being here for all
you people that are here live and
everybody in the chat right now I'll do
this again I'm gonna put up the
um
you know sometimes I put up an
engagement I'll say I'll start a q a you
know so I'm gonna put it up here uh
episode 235
Q and A if anybody has any things in the
chat there if you want to uh you know
and I'll look for those you know what I
mean
for those uh that are about to get it
to get an ad it is what it is I don't
know some new thing on YouTube but
anyways uh welcome back so
what's going on
a lot of stuff going on lots of stuff
going on I'll I'll save my succession
finale talk till the end because
obviously spoiler alert and I love
getting messages I get a lot of comments
from people who are like stop spoiling
television shows that always gets me too
uh
oh so people are already asking me
questions in the Q a so let's just go to
that real quick because this it just
didn't happen last week what's the
status of the crackers
we so funny you say that
she just moved the crackers two days ago
finally I saw the crackers removed
because because the thing is like she
don't like to keep things for too long
so the crackers were on the table and
they were opened and so she just threw
them away because I saw him in the trash
and I was like oh my God all these good
crackers are just thrown away because
this is expensive ass Air One crackers
she likes to get but yes the crackers
are gone so thank you for reminding me
about that
um
Mr dark Lumen not answering that man you
know come on dude it's like this ain't
this ain't the time or place for that
and you know what do you think answer it
yourself
uh yeah okay let's see which pod is more
fun Harlan highway or bad friends oof
that's tough I love Andrew and Bobby you
know and but Harlan like I don't know
him like that you know so but I had such
a great time on Harlan's podcast guys by
the way and you know and speaking of let
me just since we're since we're talking
about that right now let's just let me
let me just go to this right now here's
a little video preview from the Harlan's
Highway podcast man I had such a good
time on this it was so fun
Williams
and sometimes
[Music]
I don't know what the hell is wrong with
you
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
oh man had a good time with Harlan
Williams man he uh
I you have to watch that episode of
Harlan Highway
because
there was
so many
dude there was he I wanted I'm not even
gonna tell you how many of those he had
and it was just you know it was just
really freaking hilarious man
um
oh was the audio bad on that Harlan clip
oh man what was happening was there an
echo what was happening with the oh man
I gotta figure out how to stop that
oh well anyways just check it out
because I hear it fine but maybe I guess
you know what it might be that you got
how I know what well I don't even know
what it is
I have to figure it out but anyway sorry
about the audio on that one right here
somebody said any new hats uh no new
hats yet you know no new hats
uh I just get back to the live chat here
ah anyways
so anyways
um there was that yeah so I had a really
good time on uh Harlan's podcast that
was really fun so you might want to
check that out
yeah so what what was happening with the
oh it was like oh it was robotic or
whatever well see I don't know how to
get the audio
I'll have to work on that later but that
that's good to know thank you for
letting me know that that was happening
so you guys know I'm I'm a one-man show
here it's weird because what I hear
isn't what you guys hear so sorry for
anybody that if it was like weird for
you sorry about that
but he just I'm not good he had a lot of
those that that mustache nose thing that
was just funny it's just like an old
it's like the oldest joke people think
they're so funny when they say that but
it's so hacked now people have been
saying that to me for 20 years
[Laughter]
uh so all right so let's go into first
thing up let's talk about these um
Celtics man let's talk about these
Celtics
I am okay so as you know I was saying on
my podcast last week that this was a
perfect scenario for a team to come back
from O3 before it even happened I was
saying this I was saying it when they
won game four then my podcast came out
that Wednesday and I was saying this is
actually a perfect the probably the only
scenario that a team could come back
when you have game seven on your home
floor that's pretty amazing thing
Celtics choked it away yes Tatum got
hurt on the first play but to me
everything I've been saying about the
Celtics for the past month is it it just
showed itself in that game no
adjustments from Missoula he he don't
even have a veteran on that bench to
tell him like yo usually in these
situations or something he just he just
showed us an experience in his arrogance
he's so arrogant man like at the end of
the game they're at the press conference
they're like yo you shot so many threes
it wasn't working and he was like would
you change that strategy he's like no or
something he just was saying that it was
fine that they shot Seven for fifty you
know what I mean whatever the
three-point shooting was and he's just
like there was no in-game adjustments no
adjustments to that zone defense you
know what I mean like you know no
adjustment of being like okay Tatum
don't got it we gotta get him out let's
get somebody in Blake Griffin's sitting
there on the bench there's other people
on the team like let's try something new
get people in to see what we could do
you know so well I don't know it was
very it was a very disappointing I'm
disappointed because I wanted to see
history being made that's all I wanted
to see history being made that's what I
was looking forward to and it's uh but
you know at this point I'm not gonna
doubt the heat anymore
you know what I mean if you fan out
there like I feel you you've been mad
you're like hey and if you look at what
the Heat have done in the last four
years they went to the championship and
they've gone to three I think they've
been to they've been in the championship
in the Eastern Conference Conference
Finals like four out of five years like
they are a legit organization and a
legit team Jimmy Butler is a great
playoff star those undrafted players you
know they just are professionals the guy
was like that guy Martin was like oh
you're not gonna draft me he went into
the lab worked on his shot worked on his
game worked on his athleticism whatever
he did
to get himself to this point and the
culture of the Miami Heat that guy's now
a star okay like he's gonna get paid
he's a bona fide star for that team and
and then they just need like you know in
my mind I was like oh they just need one
more star but what does that mean it's
like some sort of name recognition that
guy's name's gonna be out there now and
then now it's gonna be Jimmy Butler
Martin all the guys they have on the
team adebayo you know maybe they could
pick up another piece that worked that
has that sort of mentality but I'm not
gonna doubt the Miami Heat anymore I'm
actually gonna pick the Miami Heat to
win the championship that's my thing I'm
gonna go with them now I'm gonna go with
like let's see now I want I'm going for
history I want them to finish the job I
want this eighth seed
really like 10th or 11th seed
would an old ninth they were like the
eighth or ninth or tenth seed going into
the playing game
and they're on the verge of winning the
championship I know it's a daunting task
I know the Denver Nuggets are playing
very well they have arguably the best
player in the playoffs right now in in
jokic
and you know and and Murray's going back
to his form when he was scoring you know
50 points in the playoffs against Utah
in the bubble
how fantastic he was and people keep
people forget that I mean that was great
you know and so he's there so the thing
is what's the formula for the Miami Heat
to beat the Denver Nuggets okay what's
the formula and
you know I I think I think that the
formula is this you can't stop jokic
okay so don't even try to stop him you
know I would single cover him
stay at home on the shooters and Cutters
and let him have 50 because 50 points
isn't going to win the game you know
it's not going to win the game so
to me I would be like we can't let Jamal
Murray go off so Jimmy Butler needs to
get on Jamal Murray and shut him down
shut Lamar shut Jamal Murray down let
yokich have 50 points a game go ahead
man and then y'all just have 15 to 20
from all your starters they'll Miami
wins that's what I think the formula is
I don't think they should double team
jokic he's too good of a passer you know
he's just he's such a smart player let
him have to do it and then they're gonna
be like they're gonna need other people
to step in Aaron Gordon and uh Porter Jr
and those guys are going to have to
actually step up and and play play ball
oops I just spilled water on my shirt
sorry that was such a fat guy thing
right on right on camera
anyways so
people thought I was getting a beer no
this is a liquid death
y'all thought I was getting a Bud Light
hey
anyway
so you know you gotta cut down so he you
got to make sure that jokic has like if
even if he has 50 points make sure he
only has like three assists because he
can't get to anybody else because you're
locking everybody else down so we'll see
what they do in the pick and roll in the
switch and we'll see what happens
so we'll see we'll see even if like
somebody's going somebody says if he
rebounds and assists add another 20
points to his 50. that's only 70. that
doesn't win a game you see what I'm
saying so even if even if he got 20
points and assist that's just 70. you
need you need 15 to 20 from your
starters and then and then some good
bench play from the Heat this all-around
game that they had 28 from Butler 26
from Martin 10 or 15 from Kyle Lowry
coming off the bench you know all those
guys Vincent Vincent giving you 10 15.
like all the guys that are on that Miami
team that have been balling now since
the first quarter you know you're
talking about 98 100 110 points they
could get if you hold you know hold
those other guys on different I'm not
saying it's easy I'm not saying they're
going to be able to do that I'm just
saying to me that's the strategy because
if you let jokic get like 36 but he's
got like you know 15 assists and 20
rebounds that's a whole different story
because then you that means Jamal
Murray's going off listen if Jamal
Murray gets 30 points Denver wins you
know because they're not gonna stop
jokic right so it's gonna be a very
interesting thing my thing is this we
keep doubting Miami we keep going like
is this the team that like is Denver the
team that's like oh we're just so much
better than you sorry
Denver and the Celtics Celtics had the
best record Milwaukee and Celtics had
the best record in the league it was
Milwaukee Celtics then Denver then uh
whatever the other team was over there
had the best records I mean Celtics were
a great team too
Miami found a way I'm just saying
we can't just sit here and doubt Miami
anymore okay so all right so that's uh
that's it that's my talk for that okay
um all right let's go into some um crazy
let's go into some crazy stories it's
not even a crazy story so much as it's
about you know Mr Elon Musk right this
guy brilliant dude you know what I mean
so you know he has this thing now if you
guys have been paying attention to it
you know
the FDA he he wants to put a neural link
that a chip in people's brains that
interacts with your brain and computer
and you know
and they're going to start testing it on
human beings I think they got finally
got FDA
approval
um
I I don't know
this is from my title in my title of the
show I said Gen X Tech you know and this
is what I want to talk about right now
first of all
I have an issue with Elon Musk being so
hard on AI like he's very much like we
have to really be careful about AI but
at the same time wanting to put a
computer in our heads
maybe it's not Apples to Apples but it
just seems like whoa that that seems
like a jump
you know as I think about so you know
what is this going to mean for the
future you know what does it mean for
the future man
and
I'm Gen X guys I've found out you know
Gen X
it's like 1970 it's like 1970 or
something
I forgot what the the Gen X uh time
frame is but
I think that my generation
um people you know late 40s early 50s
we lived through a huge technological
boom one of the largest in human history
for for the impact that that technology
has had on the modern era
so and that is
cell phones
computers
and the internet
and all of community and then when I say
cell phones internet all of
communication and information gathering
including entertainment
I saw all this happen I had a Commodore
64 when I was a kid it was the first
computer you know it was one of the
first computers sold to the public and
it was just a stupid computer with a
word processor and you could do little
like you know you could you could
program it to have a conversation with
you it was it was weird I don't and then
you had these weird video games also you
know that and that goes with that
computers is the launch of all that
so I saw the first iteration of this I
had a apple 2C when an apple first came
out you know and so to me all of the
computer technology that we have now is
just an advanced iteration of the of the
original so it's nothing necessarily new
just the advancement of it and we've
seen like it get better in the same way
you have like an iPhone one and then you
know now you look at the first iPhone to
the iPhone 15 it you know you look at
them and they look pretty much the same
the technology doesn't feel like so it
far Advanced even though probably when
you really narrow it down you know it
really is but again it's just like it's
not it's not a new technology it's just
an improvement on what's already there
so I always would ask the question to
myself is what's next like what's the
thing that's gonna wow us what's the
thing that we're gonna be like whoa
because not just wowest but scare us
technology is scary
my great aunt I'll never forget I'm
visiting her in Belize I'm a little kid
and they just got a refrigerator and
they just got a television okay
um you know they still got Vats outside
collecting rain water that's how rural
it was for them so and I just remember
my aunt
telling me first of all they wouldn't
keep the refrigerator on because she
didn't want to waste electricity so they
would turn the refrigerator off they
would unplug it you know like they just
didn't understand it but I remember her
also with the television she was like
please don't turn the TV to channel 13
because the devil is on that channel
and I realized she was talking about
like King Kong
the King Kong movie was and that was the
devil so
that was scary to her you know imagine
you're living in a world where there's
no you just have the radio and now
you're seeing pictures and then like
you're refrigerating your food
you know like imagine if you're a person
that like you know you had to eat food
right away because it would spoil like
that's how you bought food now you have
the ability to like keep stuff in the
refrigerator for weeks and you're used
to things spoiling like that must been a
bit of Mind trip of being like oh I
can't trust that like imagine that
thought process we're experiencing that
again right now I feel like and I feel
like my people my generation and people
older than me are having trouble with
what's happening right now and the first
thing is AI I talked about it last week
but I just want to touch on it again you
know anything that you come out with
there's going to be a negative there's
going to be people who are going to take
advantage of it and use it the wrong way
just think of like dynamite you know uh
when they you know they were using it
for making fireworks and it was supposed
to be entertaining and then someone took
that and turned it into a weapon there's
always things like that you look at the
internet I mean the internet for
instance must have been super scary for
some people at the time because it was
like whoa here's all this information
and it was like and it's still happening
right now the fact that people can just
say whatever they want about a person
with no evidence no facts no real you
know no no due process someone could
just make a claim about someone
put it on the internet and everyone
believes it
but that doesn't work in court
it doesn't work in real life but the
public thought that's all it takes it's
so dangerous right that's what happens
on the Internet it's so dangerous people
could just say whatever they want
if someone could say you know they just
tweet things and and then you know you
know there's no facts or evidence at all
when you say something bad about someone
look what happened with Johnny Depp and
uh Amber Heard man like we don't really
you know what we still don't really know
what happened but she wrote an art she
wrote an op-ed piece accusing him of
things and he lost his career then he
was like I'm coming back I'm fighting
you on this because to me it's like get
it right
you know
like even a reputable news organization
like the Washington Post
they messed up by just blanketly putting
that out that's the world we live in now
where information is just it's so wild
you know and you know people's lives are
being ruined you know what I mean and to
me it doesn't service alleged victims in
any way by just putting claims out it's
like no let's let's figure this out
there's nuanced every situation let's
find out you know let's say that's like
if someone is guilty of a uh and then
you jump to
ABCD you know you can't do that you
can't do that without any facts or
evidence you know what I mean
so anyways that's the internet
you know so now we're able to gather
information but who who put that
information out
that was always the thing like like it
was like you just make a website and you
put information on it and someone
Googles that information and then
they're seeing that website but who's to
say that this website is correct like
how do we determine what is factual what
is researched what is you know that this
is real information
you know that's the the scary part to
the internet but
we can't put it away man
there's child pornography there's you
know how to make bombs there's there's
so many like bad things on the internet
but at the same time there's also look
how I'm connecting with you right now
this is because of the internet
you know entertainment and and there are
great you know you know
encyclopedias and there's organizations
that have you know a great reputation
that have integrity that we can gather
information from it's a way to connect
the world and so there's so many good
things to it also we can't just look we
can't just be like well this is scary
and these are all the bad things that
are going to happen so we should get rid
of it you know or we shouldn't do it you
know we just have to like upgrade our
thought process we have to upgrade our
laws you know I've talked about this in
the past too but it's like my friend's
motorcycle got stolen and he had one of
those air tags on it but because it was
in they they the people know so they
stole the bike and they put it in an
apartment so when the cops came they're
like well we don't have we we need a
search warrant and there's no you know
those laws need to be upgraded that's an
old school thinking the problem with
technology it moves so fast and we're
not moving with it
immediately the law should change if
there's an air tag on a thing and stolen
you have your phone you're showing the
police you should be able to report to
Cops give it this that's the due process
that's the probable cause and they
should be able to go do something about
it
it's just an old school thinking you
can't stop progress exactly somebody in
the chat just said you can't stop
progress and progress comes with pros
and cons here's an example of old school
thinking holding us back
when you deposit a check on your phone
right you deposit a check okay I'm not
going to show you the check amount and
all that but I'm just saying they still
make you take a picture of the back of
the check the endorsement that is the
dumbest [__] ever
it's so dumb
you know it is so dumb
that they make you
sign the back of the check and take a
picture of that
that's because the people that came up
with this
they're like well we have to have a
physical check they can't wrap their
brains around the fact that all you need
are the numbers the amount and the
accounts are connected money flows from
one to the other they they can't wrap
their brains around just being like well
I guess we don't really need to back it
a check you know what I mean it's just
an old school check thing that they
didn't want to let go of it's dumb hey
banking people You're dumb okay that's
archaic get rid of that process it
shouldn't even be like that you know you
take a picture of the front you're done
you can't even tell that the back of the
check is that check
so anyway but that's I know what it was
it was people sitting around being like
well we got to have the endorsement you
have to have the signature what if you
don't have the fingertip you know what I
mean it's like it's it's the same way
when you go to you go to a store and you
buy something and you use Apple pay or
you use your phone Google whatever
you're just using your phone to tap and
they still want you to sign why why are
we signing when this is my phone I have
to double click the thing you know put
my face ID so that they know it's me
once I put that in that's me this that's
me that security process has already
been done the hell am I signing the back
a receipt for how about this why am I
even getting a receipt you go to CVS in
the receipt it's like nine feet long why
why are you giving me a receipt now
it should be immediately connected to
your credit card the credit card the
receipt should go right to your email
immediately or it just goes right to
your phone if you pay with Apple pay
like what are we doing it's like holding
on to the old school way of thing and we
are moving too fast for that we're
moving too fast for that so I say all
that to say
I'm talking to my new cousin from my you
know Rachel's side of the family Jake
and he's like an engineer or something
like that you know and he's working with
AI
and he's a young guy he just graduated
college he's so excited about AI like so
excited about it and I looked at him and
I was like oh wow I'm old I have to
remember that progress can't be stopped
and this generation sees the potential
and the benefits
I mean if AI can solve math problems for
us if AI can like you know go through
equations where you know it's going to
help us cure cancer cure herpes cure
AIDS uh you know come up with a complex
uh solutions to make sure we're we're
you know we're efficiently using our
fuel and our resources that's great you
know okay so the scary part is jobs are
going to be taken away right so that
means then we have to catch up by
learning different things
different professions different you know
we have to get into the tech World
faster this is like you know what they
were all what presidents talk about
all the time Obama was talking about
this man like you know different
training that we need so whatever these
like jobs that who wants to work in a
factory if we can get robots to make
everything and produce everything it's
like okay then yeah now we don't need
that anymore so now you could learn
something else maybe this will be good
for art and like uh you know people can
go into that and we could start
appreciating things differently like we
don't have to spend as much money on the
production of things because now they
maybe they don't have to charge as much
so things will be cheaper I don't know
there's just so many different things we
have to we have to just change our
thought process we do we have to change
how we look at the world and and Ai and
then this thing too I and that's why I
have an issue with Elon Musk having a
problem with AI I think he has a problem
with AI because we don't need smart
people anymore so like you know smart
people that that super rich but when
you're super smart and you're on The
Cutting Edge and you have that
information and you're saying the
average Joe could just be at home and
solving equations with their AI computer
you know a computer uh tell me how to
solve this and the computer's helping
you you mean we won't need Elon Musk you
know what I mean
I'm just being facetious we're always
going to need smart people with ideas
you know but I think that his idea of
you know hey this is scary hey is the AI
going to become sentient who knows maybe
but let's get ready for that
it's just
so this neural link is one of those
things it's this sort of like scary
technology like the television to
migrain Aunt to the this new generation
or the the the this older generation
it's like you're not gonna put no chip
in my head I mean I totally get that
mentality the scariness of that the
thought of like are you gonna put a chip
in my head
but if that's going to help with my mom
has dementia what if the neural link is
going to help
cure that or what if the neural link is
going to help us you know remember
things and and store a ton of
information that we need to do our jobs
what if I can like keep all my jokes I
can just imagine of knowing every single
one of my jokes is in my head and I'll
be like okay let me reorganize that hey
computer uh organize the the set with
this this I mean how it's going to help
us even when it comes to like like the
writer strike right now you can't put AI
away they're so worried about it but
it's like it's just gonna be a tool that
we're gonna use
Riders are going to be using the AI help
me I'm thinking of a story this this and
this AI starts to put it together and
then the human being comes in and they
add emotions and the human touch to it I
mean it's just it's just a tool that
we're gonna have to use it's never gonna
go away guys and so all the people
around my age who are scared of
technology and like you know like Ice
Cube was like AI is demonic like that
attitude is just like my great aunt man
my great aunt who looked at the
television and saw pictures of King Kong
and she was like that's demonic it's the
same sort of like archaic thinking that
we have to get past and the young people
of today are going to be the ones
they're gonna they're gonna push us into
the future and it's a scary future it's
an unknown future but it's gonna be
fantastic and then we just have to
embrace it
all right guys well [__] that was a lot
it's already 42 minutes I don't even
know
okay um there are some crazy stories uh
you know from Instagram that I wanted to
talk about too and you know what and
this one goes right into it when it
comes to stories about the future of
technology and here's one of them right
here scientists in Japan claim lab-grown
babies could exist as soon as 2028.
2028 what
there's so much to be impacted by this I
didn't really look a lot into it it just
was like man this is where we're going
so it's like you won't need a surrogate
it's like you don't want to tear up your
body so then it's like is this going to
be a safe way to do pregnancy it's like
you go you know you now you can save you
save your sperm you get the woman's eggs
you save them in a thing and you go okay
we're ready to have a baby and now
there's just going to be this sort of
laboratory organic safe process to make
sure there's no defects to make sure
there's the babies getting all the
nutrients and everything that it needs
um and then it's like here we go you
know then here's your health then
they're going to take out here's your
healthy baby you know that's something
else is that the future where women
won't have to do that anymore
and maybe that's great maybe it's like
for women
you know now they can live
you know they can through their 20s and
30s all through their 20s and 30s they
could just be doing their thing and then
you know you could be now you're 39 30
you know 41 years old and you're like ah
it's time to for me to I want to have a
baby now you know and then they go to
the lab and they go yeah you know here's
my uh card my sperm is in safe two four
five and then they you know the the eggs
and sperm and then you boom here you put
it together you know or maybe now it's
gonna be
you freeze your eggs your eggs are at
the laboratory and now you're like
you're you're a single woman and you
want to have a kid and now you just you
know you now you have the app and you're
swiping through all the the potential
sperm donors and you're like ah yeah put
my eggs with this one right here you
know what I mean you're just making an
order you're like give me this and then
the next thing you know you got this
this baby so who knows man that's a
scary scary story I totally scary but
it's just like that again look how I
said it I feel like what the people I
was talking about like that's like wow
that's how we're gonna do it weird other
crazy Instagram story this one I take
offense to
an airline is gonna start weighing
passengers before they board flights
talk about fat Shaman man you know what
I mean I I hope this is gonna be a
private thing I hope it's not like right
at the gate
you checking in and then there's a thing
for your luggage and then there's a
thing for you so you put
you know what I mean like what if like
you combine weight has to be like it
can't be over 250 or something like
total weight so you're like okay so you
have to weigh a certain amount oh man
yeah you can't take this much luggage on
because you weigh you're taking up your
allotment of weight for the plane I mean
damn talk about fat shaming you know
what I mean
I mean they say they the story is saying
that they're doing it for safety there
the airline is looking for those
traveling on International networks as a
part of the passenger way survey it's
for a survey it's an essential
initiative to ensure the safe and
efficient operation of the aircraft
so there's got to be some kind of like
well how about this how about don't have
so many seats on the damn plane how
about take off some seats [__] you ever
think of that how about you don't need
to make as much money as you're making
by cramming so many people on there how
about take out all the middle seats so
we can make sure the plane's gonna be
under a certain weight why are you
putting it on us so now I got to be 106
pounds to fly your flight nah man
fat people gotta go see their grandma
too you know what I mean it's like
what's lizzo gonna do she have to fly
private all the time
I don't like this
I don't like this at all
so that's just a crazy story
but you know we'll see we'll see where
it's going you know
then the last one is this and speaking
of flights
this dude opened the plane mid-flight
because he was uncomfortable man I fly a
lot
and I actually fly in the
the
what is the emergency exit row sometimes
too when when the first class is full
and I don't get to upgrade that has more
legroom I've been uncomfortable and it's
never in my mind ever thought like oh
you know what let me just open this door
real quick let some air in like like
well there's more to the story there's
actually there's actually
um more to the story and I have it right
here
um let me go to that oh look at me
switching between stuff here it is yeah
he was arrested a man arrested and
opened a door in the Asia Asiana
Airlines is that the Asiana Asiana I
don't know how to say that
yeah it was Landing in South Korea and
he said uh okay the man in his 30s said
he was feeling suffocated and want to
get off quickly
what
what that's the what segment right now
somebody said I should have a what
segment and here it is
what
you wanted to get off quickly
you in the sky wait I guess that's
getting off quick do you have a
parachute with you what you gonna do
when we land they're gonna land and
you're just gonna like hop out what you
gonna do
I don't understand what you're gonna do
when you get to the gate what do you
think's gonna happen when you get there
you're gonna just jump out the plane and
the ground crew is gonna be like hey
dude yeah just go to that door over
there like
mental illness man
they got in there it is right there the
police said the man claimed during
questioning that he was stressed after
losing his job according to the airport
I mean stress I mean this is this is
this goes into like yo
Stress Management
work on that
all right guys we're finishing off
spoiler alert spoiler alert spoiler
alert
succession
the final episode of succession man
oh my God
succession was I know I'm doing a little
ASMR when I'm drinking for you people
that are just listening like what was
that that's just me drinking my water
ah
anyways
I'm making you thirsty go get you
something to drink go get that try Okay
so
succession one of the great shows that
has been made on Max now it's Max it's
not HBO Max it's just max now
um
yeah this was great now here's my thing
with like Seasons like when they go this
is the last season of a show right and
then all of a sudden the purpose lines
up great the writers the the
performances the the showrunner the crew
like how they create the show how the
show is driven with this idea that this
is the end it always makes for the best
work
that this
the last
last when Logan died spoiler alert I
told you spoilers but you know Logan
died in like in the middle of the season
they killed him off
so that was something that they wanted
to do and then the show became about
these crazy kids and like what they were
gonna you know what they were gonna do
you know and so
everything leading up to this show is
like it's just as an actor myself and
just like being an artist there was such
great work on this season finale and the
the last four episodes of the show and I
love watching that after the show they
have this like uh behind the scenes look
and you know the actors talking to
creators talk and just hearing how they
did it they did a lot of like
eight camera shoots and they just shot
continuously this funeral scene like the
Logan's funeral was like oh it was so
great and um Kelly Calkins brother
whatever Culkin that guy on the right
there he oh my God so good
you know he was good like d this family
is just the worst you know they're just
the worst privileged brilliant in some
ways conniving and sneaking in the
sneaking in the others and this guy Tom
who's just been the sort of snake in the
grass the whole time married to shiv and
Tom has just kind of like always looked
out for himself you get the impression
that he even married her for because she
was in the in the uh the Logan family
the the Roy's you know the and he like
joined this family and and their
relationship is so toxic but yet there's
love and respect there like the
disrespect they have for how evil each
at the you know just how selfish they
both are they're so selfish you know so
as you know in the in in the final
season there's this company uh uh Goji
or whatever the name of the company is
they're trying to buy so Logan before he
dies is trying to sell he's like you
know know what I want out but I'm going
to keep this one division ATM which is
like Fox news or like CNN you know what
I mean but it's more like [__] he's like
I'm gonna keep that I'm gonna do my own
thing but I'm selling everything else
they own cruise ships movie companies
they don't it's like a big conglomerate
that they own and they're gonna sell it
to this company and so it's about that
and the kids you know they don't want to
sell they they want more money they want
and then they realize they don't like
that guy that they're selling to and
they're like nah [__] this guy let's
keep the company ourselves their father
dies and they're like you know what I
think we could do it and now it's this
whole thing where there's no closure
with their father who was just a bastard
he just was like a hard ass father who
didn't really show them love but he made
them who they are you know and so then
there's all these cryptic messages of
like I want this one to succeed and
there's stuff in the will and you know
Roman was talking with his father before
he died and he was led to believe he was
going to be something but he's just weak
he's just a weak [__] with a terrible
mouth you know
and then shiv is just this like Ugh like
there's just no loyalty and she's just
like so out for herself at all times and
then and then uh um the the other one he
uh he's just like you know
uh I I I I hate these people and that's
why I love the performances of the
actors they just did such a great job
because you have such distinct feelings
and they Greg the guy in the back there
he was such a snake like they're all
snaking the grasses you know
so then they're always going after each
other the brothers and sisters always
like they're together one time and then
they're not together anymore and they
were just showing that and then the
season finale is just great where like
you know she feels betrayed by the guy
that you know she's gonna be the CEO of
the company because when he takes it
over so now you know her brothers are
like but we want to stop this deal and
we're going to take over but she feels
left out she's like yeah but she left me
out of this you guys are running the
company together you just left me out
she was like now I have an opportunity
to run the company myself and get you
guys out and then the guy backstabs her
and she's like all right she's back with
her brothers and then they're they're
like boom and then there's this final
scene where they're sitting there and
they're voting the board of directors is
voting like are they gonna are they
gonna sell the company you know and then
she sits there and it's her vote it's
you know it's like six just it's six to
six and she's the final vote and she
gets up and leaves and then the brother
and sisters have this epic talk about
themselves and
oh it was just everything was fantastic
the last few episodes like that one
episode where Tom and shiv are like
laying it all out on the line like let's
be honest with each other for once you
know
uh
it's it's listen
I need you to
watch it if you haven't ever watched
succession start on the first episode
and just watch this show unfold
and these people unfold it's like it
doesn't necessarily glorify the rich at
all so much as like it's just this is
The Human Condition and what happens to
people and how much family can really
affect you
because their mother is terrible
but anyways
great final episode
it didn't feel like I felt like they
left room for this could go on but I
don't know who knows
who knows I don't know why they ended it
after four seasons you know sometimes a
story needs to be told and then it's
done you know so
yeah pretty amazing good job
um you know what I mean so
let's see here
um oh wait I don't want to end this let
me go to it go to this oops what just
happened here
I don't know what I just did
I don't know how do I see this I'm
trying to see oh here we go here we go
here we go guys let me just make sure
that I got if there were any more
questions okay there were some more
questions and I'll finish up here
um have you ever been to Japan have not
been to Japan but I want to go to Japan
and I know how advanced Japan is
somebody said it sounds like the
Demolition Man with Wesley Snipes and
Sly Stallone oh you're so right yeah I
know with the babies that's so true man
um but in the closing uh dark Loom and
asked me nuggets or heat how many games
I think heat in seven that's that's what
I would like to see
I'm going for the underdog in this one
guys Heaton seven
all right okay guys
um
now let's get back to this
oh I forgot about that let's get back to
this guys I just I want to thank you for
being here uh you know you know how we
do uh yeah please subscribe and share
and and uh you know on the show and I'm
you know I'm on Twitch I'm gonna be on
Twitch in a little while right after
this maybe like 10 minutes I'll be back
on Twitch so you know come come check
that out
check me out there and
um what else you know be a patreon
person you know if you want to just to
support me you know support the show you
know so I could keep going I'm on
episode 235 can't even believe that you
know can you leave them on episode 235
it's crazy but you know what we do
so anyways y'all I want to thank you for
watching
Griffin Griffin if you want to send me a
Beat
recap
[Music]
you might get slapped
oh yeah
rap recap
oh man style
um what's the Celtics joke
now they broke
they gave up hope
not a heat moving on
[Music]
with
I'm picking them in seven
[Music]
succession finale right up my alley
there was no dilly dally
[Music]
like hairy man Sally
hey I is here to stay
there's no other way hey hey
go
you're doing it doing it again
tell your friend
all right y'all
that's ripping with Griffin thanks for
watching
and I will see you next week
see you next week